Google Cloud updates
I love a reference sheet don't you and
we've got a new one and it's all about
networking Basics version two of our
networking 101 reference sheet has even
more resources to expand on version one
including data center networking terms
go ahead and check it out Google Cloud
cdmc certified architecture will help
you migrate that sensitive data with
confidence and who's that for videos
cisos data platform Architects and
Engineers data owners and data stewards
check out the white paper and source
code for more details check out the
links below for everything that we
covered on this week's